--No sé su nombre. --Miembro de la audiencia: Howard, Howard.
Thom Mayne: ¿Howard? Estaba sentado al lado de Howard; no lo conozco, obviamente,
y me dijo: "espero que Ud. no sea el próximo".
(Risas)
Muy, muy buen número.
Como que borré todo de mi mente para seguir eso.
Bueno, por algún lado tengo que empezar. Me interesa...
Hago prácticamente lo mismo pero sin mover el cuerpo.
Y en lugar de usar figuras humanas para desarrollar ideas de tiempo y espacio
trabajo en el mundo mineral. Trabajo con materia más o menos inerte.
Organizo la materia, bueno, es un poco diferente
porque un arquitecto versus, digamos, una compañía de baile
es en definitiva una negociación entre el mundo interior
el mundo conceptual, de las ideas, el mundo de las aspiraciones
de las invenciones en relación al mundo exterior
con sus limitaciones, y los pesimistas.
Porque debo decir que a lo largo de mi carrera
si hay algo consistente, es que siempre me han dicho que no podría.
Sin importar lo hecho, lo que haya intentado,
todo el mundo decía que no podría.
Y esto es algo continuo en todo el espectro de las varias
clases de realidades en que uno confronta con las ideas.
Y para ser arquitecto en cierta forma uno tiene que negociar entre izquierda y derecha
negociar entre este lugar muy privado en el que ocurren las ideas
y el mundo exterior, para luego hacerlo comprensible.
Puedo empezar desde muchos lugares porque este proceso a la vez...
pienso que es muy distinto de alguna de las sesiones de la mañana
en las que uno tenía una especie de idea muy clara, muy lineal
como la última, digo, la de Howard
que pienso el proceso creativo de la arquitectura
el proceso de diseño es extremadamente sinuoso. Es laberíntico.
Es la idea calvinista de que el camino más rápido entre dos puntos
es la línea sinuosa y no la recta.
Y, definitivamente, mi vida ha sido un poco así.
Voy a empezar con simples
nociones de cómo organizamos las cosas.
Básicamente lo que hacemos es intentar dar coherencia al mundo.
Hacemos objetos físicos, edificios
que forman parte de una proceso de acreción que hace ciudades.
Y esas cosas son el reflejo de los procesos
y el tiempo en que son hechos.
Y yo intento hacer una síntesis de la manera en que vemos el mundo
y los territorios útiles como materia generativa.
Porque, en realidad, todo lo que siempre me interesa como arquitecto
es la manera en que las cosas son producidas porque eso hago, ¿correcto?
Y no se fundamenta en una noción a priori.
No me interesa en absoluto concebir algo en mi mente
y decir: "Así es como se ve". De hecho, alguien mencionó...
quizá fue Ewan en su presentación...
que alguien decía que los arquitectos
hacen lo que los empresarios piden
es lo que el mundo corporativo espera
cuando quieren que algo parezca preconcebido. Ehh... ¡Vaya!
Para mí eso no es así, de ninguna manera.
No tengo ningún interés en eso para nada.
La arquitectura es el comienzo de algo porque...
si no se está familiarizado con los primeros principios,
si no estás involucrado del todo,
el comienzo de ese proceso generativo, es pura decoración de tortas.
No tengo nada en contra de la decoración de tortas, ni de los decoradores,
si alguien hace decoración de tortas...
no es algo que me interese hacer.
Entonces, en la formación de las cosas, al darles forma...
al concretar estas cosas
todo empieza con alguna noción de organización.
Y me he interesado durante 30 años en una serie de complejidades
donde se ejerce una serie de fuerzas para soportar
y entender que el resultado final de eso
representa al edificio en cuestión.
Hay una relación contínua entre los inventos,
que son privados, y la realidad; algo importante para mí.
Un proyecto exhibido en Copenague hace 10 años,
era el modelado de un hipocampo...
la zona cerebral que almacena memoria a corto plazo...
y su documentación creativa
a través de dibujos que literalmente pretendían organizar dicha experiencia.
Esto tiene que ver con la noción de caminar un kilómetro
observando en cada kilómetro un objeto de deseo
y ubicándolo dentro de esto.
Y la idea era que se podía crear una organización
construída no sobre coherencias sino basada en incongruencias y aleatoriedad.
Me interesé mucho en esta noción de aleatoriedad
dado que produce trabajo arquitectónico
y que se relaciona con la noción de ciudad,
una noción de acreción de la ciudad
que conduce a varias ideas de organización.
Llegando así a ideas más amplias de construcciones
que se encuentran en la multiplicidad de sistemas.
Y no es un solo sistema el que hace el trabajo.
Es la relación, la dinámica entre sistemas,
la que tiene el poder de transformar e inventar
y producir una arquitectura que... que de otro modo no existiría.
Y esos sistemas podrían identificarse
y agruparse.
Y, por supuesto, hoy con la tecnología informática
y el prototipado rápido, etc., tenemos los mecanismos
para entender y responder a estos sistemas
y para permitirles acomodarse a los distintos alojamientos de funcionalidades
porque eso es lo que hacemos.
Producimos espacios que alojan actividad humana.
Y lo que me interesa no es el estilo del espacio,
sino su relación ya que realza la actividad humana.
Y remite directamente a la idea de construcción de ciudades.
Este es un proyecto que acabamos de terminar en Penang
para un proyecto de ciudad muy, muy grande, que surgió directamente de este proceso
que es producto de la multiplicidad de fuerzas que lo producen.
Y el proyecto (de nuevo, una competencia enorme, enorme)
sobre el Río Hudson de Nueva York
que nos solicitaron hace tres años, que usa estos procesos.
Y lo que están viendo son las posibilidades que tienen que ver
con la generación de la ciudad cuando uno aplica la metodología
que usa nociones de estas fuerzas múltiples,
que trata con la enormidad del problema, con la complejidad del problema,
cuando diseñamos ciudades con conglomerados cada vez más grandes.
Porque uno de los problemas de hoy es
que la aglomeración económica produce una aglomeración de desarrollo
y a medida que crecen los conglomerados necesitamos
cada vez procesos de investigación más complejos para resolver estos problemas.
Esto nos lleva directo a la Villa Olímpica.
Estuve en Nueva York el lunes en la presentación ante el COI.
Ganamos la competencia... ¿cuándo fue? ¿hace nueve meses?
De nuevo, un reflejo directo del uso de estos procesos
para desarrollar organismos sumamente complicados, a gran escala.
Y luego, también, funcionaba con estrategias amplias.
En este caso sólo usamos 6 de las 24 hectáreas de tierra
y las 18 hectáreas eran un parque que se volvería el legado de la Villa Olímpica.
Y sería el segundo parque más grande del municipio, etc.
Su ubicación, claro, en el medio de Manhattan (está en Hunters Point).
Y luego la idea más amplia de construcción de la ciudad
comienza a tener influencia directa en la arquitectura
en los elementos que constituyen el esquema más amplio
los edificios en sí, y empieza a guiarnos.
La arquitectura para mí ha sido la investigación de una multiplicidad de fuerzas
provenientes de, literalmente, cualquier lado.
Por eso puedo comenzar esta charla por varios lugares
y he elegido tres o cuatro para contarles.
Y también tiene que ver con un interés en
con la vastedad del territorio que abarca la arquitectura.
Literalmente se relaciona con todo en términos de conocimiento.
No existe nada que, de algún modo, no
tenga un tejido conectivo.
Este es Jim Dine, es la ausencia de presencia, etc.
Es la vestimenta, la piel, sin la presencia del personaje.
Se volvió una especie de idea para la noción del área de un proyecto
y se usó en un proyecto en el que podíamos desentrañar esa superficie
era una idea figurativa que iba a ser desdoblada
para trasformarse en un espacio muy complejo.
Y la idea era la relación del espacio
que estaba formado por el doblez de la imagen
y la dialéctica o el conflicto entre la figuración
y esa claridad de la imagen
y la complejidad del espacio, que estaban dialogando.
Y nos hizo repensar completamente nuestra manera de trabajar
y de hacer las cosas
lo que nos condujo a ideas más cercanas al diseño de moda cuando aplanamos la superficie
para volverlas a juntar en combinaciones espaciales.
Este fue el primer prototipo en Corea
trabajando con un envoltorio dinámico
y luego la misma característica de la tela.
Tiene identidad material, es translúcida y porosa,
nos da una idea diferente de lo que es la piel de un edificio.
Y eso se convierte de inmediato en otro proyecto.
Este es el edificio Caltrans de Los Ángeles.
Y estamos viendo la piel y el cuerpo de manera separada.
De nuevo, es una noción muy, muy simple.
Si nos fijamos en la mayoría de los edificios
lo que vemos es el edificio, la fachada, eso es el edificio.
Y, de repente, como que nos alejamos de eso
y estamos separando la piel del cuerpo
y eso nos va a llevar a un criterio de rendimiento más amplio
del cual voy a hablar en un minuto.
Y vemos cómo cuelga
y se diferencia del cuerpo.
Y luego, de nuevo, el edificio en sí,
en el centro de Los Ángeles, justo enfrente al City Hall.
Y, a medida que se mueve toma partes de la tierra. Se dobla.
Es parte de, una especie de sistema de signos,
que formaba parte de una especie de legado de Los Ángeles...
la señalización en dos y en tres dimensiones, etc.
Y luego nos permite penetrar la obra misma.
Es transparente y permite comprender, pienso,
lo que resulta siempre más interesante en todo edificio
que es su proceso real de construcción.
Y es el... como el más, probablemente el tipo de territorio más intenso
del trabajo, que no está ocupado
porque la arquitectura siempre es más interesante en un mecanismo
cuando está separada de la función
y este es un área que permite eso.
Y luego la piel comienza a transformarse en otros materiales.
Estamos usando luz como material de construcción en este caso.
Estamos trabajando con Keith Sonnier en Nueva York
y estamos haciendo esta gran sala exterior
que es posible en Los Ángeles, y que es en sí un reflejo
de los entornos urbanos, urbanos contemporáneos
que pueden encontrarse en Shibuya, en la Ciudad de México
o en São Paulo, etc.,
que tiene que ver con la activación de la ciudad durante un gran lapso de tiempo.
Y eso era en gran medida parte de la noción
del objetivo urbano de este proyecto de Los Ángeles.
Y, nuevamente, todo esto promueve la transparencia.
Y una imagen que puede estar más cerca de hablar del uso de la luz como medio
que la luz se vuelve literalmente un material de construcción.
Bueno, eso inmediatamente se volvió algo más amplio... y como un alcance.
Y, otra vez, estamos viendo una especie de bosquejo temprano
en el que estoy entendiendo ahora
que la piel puede ser una transición entre el piso y la torre.
Este es un edificio de San Francisco que está en construcción.
Y ahora se convirtió en algo mucho, mucho más amplio como problema
y tiene que ver con el rendimiento.
Este será el primer edificio de los EE.UU. que sacará...
bueno, no puedo decir que sacará el aire acondicionado. Es un híbrido.
Quería algo puro, pero no pude obtenerlo.
Es una actitud equivocada, en realidad, porque el híbrido es probablemente más interesante.
Pero sacamos el aire acondicionado de la torre.
Quedó algo de aire acondicionado en la base
pero la piel ahora se mueve por hidráulica.
Fuerza el aire... mediante un efecto Venturi, si no hay viento.
Se ajusta continuamente. Y sacamos el aire acondicionado.
Enorme, algo grande. Medio millón de dólares de diferencia al año.
10 de ellos... es poco menos de 93 mil metros cuadrados
75 mil metros cuadrados...
10 de ellos abastecerían a Sausalito... con esa diferencia.
Y ahora estamos mirando, a medida que los proyectos crecen en escala,
a medida que se vuelven... que encuentran problemas más amplios
que expanden esa suerte de capacidades
en términos de rendimiento.
Bueno, podría también empezar aquí.
Podríamos hablar de la relación
en un sentido más biológico de la relación entre el edificio y el suelo.
Bueno, nuestra investigación... mi generación al menos,
gente que fue a la escuela a finales de los '60,
ha generado un cambio en el enfoque interno de la arquitectura.
observando la arquitectura en su propio territorio
estábamos mucho más influenciados por el cine
que por lo que sucedía en el mundo del arte, etc.
Este es, por supuesto, Michael Heizer.
Y cuando vi esto, primero una imagen y luego personalmente
cambió totalmente mi manera de pensar a partir de entonces.
Y comprendí que un edificio podría ser realmente
una expansión de la superficie de la Tierra
y eso cambió completamente mi idea de base de edificio en el sentido más básico.
Y luego, bueno, él probablemente estaba mirando esto... esto es Nazca
hace 700 años... las más sorprendentes esculturas en tierra de cuatro kilómetros.
Son algo increíble.
Y eso nos llevó a repensar completamente la manera de dibujar, de trabajar.
Este es el primer boceto de una secundaria en Pomona.
Bueno, sea lo que sea es un modelo, una especie de idea conceptual.
Se trata de la reconfiguración de la tierra para hacerla habitable.
fueron 19 mil metros cuadrados de relleno que hizo posible una escuela
en la superficie de esa tierra.
Allí está modelada como si fuera el desarrollo de una pieza de trabajo.
Y ahí está, de nuevo, cuando se comenzaba a resolver tectónicamente
y luego está la escuela.
Y, por supuesto, nos interesaba...
nos interesaba participar en la educación.
No me interesa para nada construir un edificio
que contenga las funciones X, Y y Z.
Lo que me interesa es cómo estas ideas
juegan en el proceso educativo de la gente joven.
Requiere una suerte de investigación
porque es un sistema que no se desarrolló de modo escultórico.
Es una idea que comenzó en mi primera discusión.
Tiene que ver con una lógica amplia, medio consistente,
y esa lógica se puede entender cuando uno ocupa el edificio.
Y hay una noción abierta... al menos
hay un intento de hacer un edificio muy abierto
que se conecte con la tierra en una manera muy diferente
porque me interesaba un enfoque muy didáctico al problema
que uno lo comprendiera.
Y el segundo proyecto que acababa de terminar en Los Ángeles
que usa alguna de estas ideas. Utiliza el paisaje como idea principal.
Luego, de nuevo, estamos haciendo la sede del NOAA
la Administración Nacional Oceánica y Atmosférica
en las afueras de Washington, Maryland.
Y así es como ellos ven el mundo.
Tienen 22 satélites a más o menos 160 kilómetros
el lugar está marcado en rojo.
Y lo que queremos hacer... bueno, los arquitectos,
si hay arquitectos en la sala, esto es la choza de Laugier.
Esta choza primitiva ha existido durante mucho tiempo.
Y queríamos construir algo similar
porque ellos se ven como los custodios del mundo
y queríamos que miren abajo a su satélite
como ven su propio lugar, ese de tres hectáreas.
y no queríamos perder nada. Queríamos que fuera verde.
Ahora mismo allí hay tres campos de béisbol,
y se van a quedar allí.
Pusimos una pieza directamente de norte a sur
y apunta las antenas a los oídos, ¿no?
Y luego justo debajo está el procesamiento, el ascensor de la misión,
y la sala de control de la misión; todos los demás espacios son subterráneos.
Y lo que ven es un portaaviones
que se guía por el cono de visión de estas antenas satelitales.
Y ese, el edificio en sí, ocupa la porción inferior
partido por una serie de canchas
y hay dos hectáreas de espacio horizontal ininterrumpido
para sus oficinas administrativas.
Y eso, a su vez, nos impulsó a mirar
proyectos de mayor escala en los que esta idea de interfaz paisaje-edificio
se vuelve un tejido conectivo.
La competencia de la nueva capital para Berlín, hace 4 años.
De nuevo, recién terminábamos el BCE
en realidad la Coop Himmelblau de Vienna, recién ganado este proyecto,
en el que el edificio estaba separado en una serie de elementos paisajísticos
que formaban parte del tejido conectivo de un parque
paralelo al río y desarrolla ideas de los edificios mismos
y se vuelve parte del tejido conectivo
de la trama social, cultural, del paisaje y del elemento recreativo de la ciudad.
Y el edificio ya no se ve como una cosa autónoma
sino como algo intrínsecamente conectado
a esta ciudad y a este lugar en este momento.
Y un proyecto realizado en Austria, el Hooper Bank,
que nuevamente usa esta idea de tipología de conexión
los edificios y morfología tradicionales
o la relación del desarrollo de la tierra como una idea
en un complejo que es una pieza de la ciudad donde podemos ver parte de él
literalmente es esta expansión,
esta especie de movimiento de la tierra que es la idea muy simple de
levantarlo para ocuparlo
y otras partes son más enérgicas e intensas.
Y puedo hablar de esa intensidad
en términos de las colisiones, de la clase de eventos que producen
que tienen que ver con reunir una serie de sistemas
y luego cuando parte de eso está en el terreno, parte de eso son elevaciones opuestas.
Uno ingresa al edificio a medida que este despega del terreno
y se vuelve parte de la idea.
Y luego la piel, esa especie de borde
todo allí promueve la dinámica, el movimiento de la construcción
como una serie de movimientos sísmicos, ¿correcto?
Se dirige a un espacio para eventos y luego se abre en lugares
que permiten mirar hacia el interior, y esos interiores, de nuevo
promueven la transparencia para el lugar de trabajo
que ha sido una suerte de interés continuo para nosotros.
Y luego, otra vez, en una especie de ambiente más tradicional
este es un alojamiento para estudiantes de grado en Toronto
y tiene mucho que ver con la relación de un edificio
como tejido conectivo de la ciudad.
La idea principal era la puerta de entrada, donde el sitio se abre
y el edificio ocupa tanto el espacio público como el privado.
Y es ese territorio de... es esa cosa.
Visité el lugar muchas veces y todos como que...
puede verse esto desde dos kilómetros como el centro exacto de la calle
y la idea es involucrar al público
involucrar a los edificios en el tejido público de la ciudad.
Y, por último, uno de los proyectos más interesantes... es un palacio de justicia.
Y quiero hablar de... esta es la Corte Suprema, por supuesto...
y bueno, estoy en contacto con Michael Hogan, el Presidente del Tribunal Supremo de Oregón.
No se puede continuar sin tener esta negociación
entre los propios valores y la relación
del personaje con el que uno trabaja y de cómo éste entiende al Tribunal
porque le muestro, por supuesto, Villa Savoy de Le Corbusier
de 1928, que es el comienzo de la arquitectura moderna
Bien, luego pasamos a esta imagen.
Y aqui comenzó el proyecto. Porque yo, como que, voy a...
me interesa el fenómeno que está ocurriendo aquí.
Y, en verdad, de lo que estamos hablando es de construir realidad.
Y soy un personaje que está muy interesado
en comprender la naturaleza de esa realidad construida
porque ya no existe tal cosa como la naturaleza. La naturaleza se fue.
La naturaleza en el sentido del siglo XIX, ¿correcto?
La naturaleza hoy es un artilugio cultural, ¿correcto?
La construimos como construímos esas ideas.
Y luego, claro, este, nuestro gobernador actual.
Y le dedicamos algo de tiempo a Conan, créase o no,
y luego eso nos llevó a las grandes diferencias de nuestros mundos
de un marco jurídico y artístico, arquitectónico.
Y nos obligó a hablar de las nociones de cómo trabajamos
y de la dinámica de eso y de otras fuentes del trabajo.
Y eso nos condujo al proyecto, al palacio de justicia
que es absolutamente parte de una negociación
entre la tradición y piezas del palacio de justicia tradicional.
Encontrarán una escalera de la misma longitud que la de la Corte Suprema.
Aquí hay un piano nobile, un arreglo utilizado en el Renacimiento.
Los tribunales se hicieron así. La piel de esta serie de capas
que reflejan incluso cantería rústica
pero que fue labrada con fragmentos de la Constitución
que formaban parte de este proceso
ubicados en un zócalo que lo define de la comunidad.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)